right here Mike bond with Rolling Stone
right here to come back and you'll have
a big game breakout game like you had
tonight just how good do you feel right
now you know I've leaned on my teammates
throughout this loaning you know what
throughout this whole process and know
this was an incredible moment for me but
um you know I'm not satisfied and
looking forward to Game three Steph what
did you make up to Marcus tonight he was
special obvious ease get more
comfortable more minutes and you know
playing aggressive when he's out there
puts a lot of pressure on their defense
and and even on our defensive end making
his presence felt blocking shots and
being in the right place and right to
him and it's a big big lift for us
I know he's been waiting a long time to
be on the stage and and obviously was
injuries he's he's taken the challenge
of inserting himself and and making that
transition smooth so it's been fun fun
to watch more to come
DeMarcus what was your reaction when you
got word that you would be starting and
what were the days or hours like leading
up to knowing you're gonna get to start
just like cold and I told Steve coming
into this I mean whatever he needed from
me I was I was okay with it if it's
coming off the bench at the start and if
it's playing you know eight minutes or
40 I'm I'm cool or whatever so uh no I
just
I'm gonna come in and help the team or
whatever's needed you know when I step
on the floor I'm gonna leave it out
there again back left Logan Murdoch NBC
Sports Bay Area DeMarcus you went
through two you know catastrophic
injuries particularly with the clot most
recently what is it in your DNA that
wouldn't let you now wouldn't let you
miss this season I mean what I want to
be on this stage this is this is what
I've worked for my entire career to be
on this stage to have this opportunity
you know to play for something but uh
you know once they told me I had to
change a slight chance you know being
able to return
it basically was up to me and the work
and the time I put in behind the injury
it was it was up to me so uh you know I
put the work in the time in and uh with
God's grace I'm able to be out here and
you know play the game that I love so uh
with that I've told y'all before I'm I
don't take any of this for granted
I've seen how quick these games can be
taken away from you so uh every chance I
get to go out there and play i'ma leave
it on the floor Jim back right staff Tim
Reynolds with the AP front on this side
you guys have used the strength in
numbers mantra now for a long time and I
mean
have there been too many more nights
where that might have run more true than
this one Steve said that he was thinking
DeMarcus his cap would be 20 minutes he
played almost 30 Quinn cook making the
threes Andre obviously with you know
with the shot that won it and there's
shot that sealed it at the end strength
in numbers I know it's been around for a
while but tonight it just had to mean a
lot more than maybe it has a lot of
nights yeah when you get to this stage
like who our DNA shows up so it's not
something you just just throw out there
to have you know nice shirts and give
out to the crowd at Oracle and have all
this marketing stuff is literally like
how we approach you know every day from
training camp to to June so how we
support each other how guys stay ready
throughout the year whether they play
you know like you said 30 minutes or
miss you know ten straight games out of
the rotation whatever it is coach always
talks about it that everybody's gonna
have a chance to help us win a
championship at some some point and just
to stick with it and be patient and it
shows itself over the course of a season
and you know tonight was huge and we
need three more wins that we needed to
keep going but that's a part of who we
are in our DNA it's not just what we say
mark here in the front stuff mark Medina
barian is your bill is set on the
broadcast I heard
in the game dealing with some kind of
illness wonder if you can kind of shed a
light on anything in regards to that and
what you tried to do to fight through it
just didn't feel right but to start the
game but and add a nothing's gonna keep
you out from playing in the finals games
if you can if you can help it so plenty
of time to recover before game 3 don't
really know what what the cause was just
didn't feel right
rush over here and step over to your
left a rash padania with Sportsnet that
third quarter not only the run but the
fact that you're getting contributions
from DeMarcus and Quinn cook and Bogut
and just kind of everybody being a part
of that how much did that ignite things
for you pretty much won us the game
because we we established our defensive
presence we got stops and and everybody
got involved in the offensive end and
you know when you come to the timeout
after you know a couple runs like that
and everybody is involved whether
they're scoring or setting screens or
you know making the assists or whatever
the case is everybody feels good and
then the the vibe is is there's just
solid and we know that we've taken
control the momentum and then it's just
about sustaining it you know down the
stretch so obviously third quarters have
been great for us
game warden couldnt get over the hump
but tonight was a different story
because of our defense and everybody
contributed to that standing in the back
right David Collins hitting a high Porto
Rico Stefan how important is you keep
your face up more than you go to San
Francisco
you keep your free up with your
teammates to the rest of the series
three of our teammates yeah you always
have you felt up how important is you
have you feel up to my face you free up
with your teammates for the World Series
oh I got confidence and faith and
everybody sets put out there on the
floor and they have the same in me so
again whoever's and out there you know
contributing and playing
and we'll get the job done and have fun
doing it back left
DeMarcus Jonathan show with da TV where
would you say you are at physically
right now how close are you to being
100% because you're still recovering
from your injury where do you feel like
you're at right now well I really don't
know I don't know I don't
race water here on the left side step
camel was called Hebrew name dot-com
Turkey I hope you live this time a final
MVP but if you will not be are you going
to be upset or you'll be still happy I
want to win a championship
that's all that matters my man
appreciate it though thank you guys